Fox News contributor Leo 2.0 Terrell the
host of the Larry Elder show Larry Elder
you both know that my kids are are into
sports I love Djokovic I've actually met
him I was actually a line judge in a
match that he had at John Mcenroe's
Tennis Academy in New York uh and I
totally cheated on behalf of the local
player and he looked at me after I
called made a horrible call he goes
that's the way it's going to be and I
said yep but it was pretty funny but the
fact is you know I thought the pandemic
was over Leo why are we not letting one
of the world's greatest athletes their
body their health is their income why
are they at this late date doing
something this discriminatory and this
dumb to one of the world's greatest
athletes
because we have the Democrats in office
and they're playing by a game of rules
that Djokovic doesn't want to play this
is one of the healthiest man on the
planet he's had the virus he has natural
immunities and the situation is very
obvious if he crossed the border across
the border goes by the uh goes across
the border he get in he can play the
game but he can't play the game because
he's not part of the democratic
hierarchy Djokovic stood by his
principles by saying that he did not
want to get the vaccine and the
Democratic party Joe Biden they're
punishing him for that I mean it's so
discriminatory Larry it makes me so
angry because you're really denying the
people of Miami and then at the U.S open
I would assume sometime in the summer
and early fall the opportunity to see
one of the world's best athletes why you
know I thought the pandemic was over Joe
said
yeah I'm a huge tennis buff as well Sean
this is the greatest tennis player
arguably uh in history and when I ran
for governor CNN spent a lot of time
interviewing me and uh asked me about
the vaccine mandates and I said young
people do not need to be vaccinated
they're not likely to get uh to get sick
if they do then not get really sick and
they're certainly not likely to be
hospitalized and not likely to die and
they said well that's not true according
to the CDC yada blah Etc now Lancet has
basically agreed with me has said that
natural immunity is as good as if not
better than uh than the the vaccine and
get this John if you play in the Miami
open and you haven't been vaccinated
that's okay you just can't come in the
country and play so it doesn't make any
sense whatsoever they're not following
the science it's again dictated from
high never mind what the science says
just do what we tell you it's about
government control Larry I'll give you
the first crack at Gavin Newsom cutting
off the state and their relationship
with Walgreens over the abortion pill I
mean he has every right to have his own
personal views but what about Freedom
what about Liberty he said to Ronda
Santos oh we're the free state of
California uh no I don't think so
well what happened is Walgreen got a
letter from 20 State Attorneys General
and said uh you can't use the mail to
sell the abortion pill in our state so
they have a legal and a fiduciary
obligation to comply with it imagine if
we're the other way around imagine if
governors of red States said you know
we're not going to do any more in state
business with Walgreens because
Walgreens is kowtowing to California and
allowing the abortion Bill to be sold in
those State they would be screaming on
high claiming that this was liberal
fascism well this was a conservative
fascism well this is liberal fascism One
In A continuing series of things that
this Governor has done up to and
including Banning the sale of new gas
powered cars by 2035 and Leo and I could
go down the Litany of all the things
that this fascist liberal Governor has
done will this guy ever make the Run do
you think Leo that Gavin Newsom we all
know he's ambitious we all know he wants
to measure the drapes at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue
anyway do you think he is planning to
run against Joe Biden because I believe
he is
let me tell you he walks to Sean and let
me be here's the good news not a single
Democratic governor has ever been
successful winning the White House
that's the good news but this guy has
checked out after he won re-election
he's a lame Doug Governor his only
ambition in life now is to run for
president while we had a a horrific
storm in Southern California people
still under the snow this guy is
vacationing he doesn't care about
California he doesn't care about the
crime situation he wants to be president
nothing else and he has basically
mentally checked out of California I
hope he runs because that tells me that
we're going to have Donald Trump or a
republican in the White House in 2024.
Larry
defund dismantle Nobel laws I'll run the
tape again this is a restaurant and all
hell breaks loose in New York
um how how much does damage have they
done now to businesses because people
are not safe we have about 30 seconds
well the number one responsibility of
government to protect people and
property and it's not happening and in
California Sean 500 000 people have left
the state in the last two years about
the same number of people that have gone
to Florida in part because of the crime
High Cost of Living bad schools and the
covet lockdowns it's the people are
voting with their feet and they will
continue to do so yeah well sudden Larry
thank you Leo thank you when we come
back hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else